hey 42 here home crack cocaine crystal
meth Krispy Kreme these are some of the
most addictive and most dangerous
recreational drugs in the world but
there's an even more dangerous drug a
substance so terrifying that it would
have bought David Bowie back down to
earth meets burundanga also known as
coppola me and by its street name
Devil's breath take this and you'll wake
up in a strange location with your bank
account empty and all your worldly
possessions missing as has happened to
many a victim of this incredibly
powerful drug burundanga is not a drug
taken recreationally in fact it's a drug
that even the most hardcore of substance
abusers
would steer well clear of burned Angus
found in the leaves roots and seeds of
the Barrichello tree
the most common way to process already
for sale on the street is by taking the
seeds from the pot and grinding them and
then bleaching them into white powder
I know another white powder how very
original the tree grows in abundance in
Colombia and not just in the wilderness
the trees can be seen lining the streets
of huge cities like Bogota and even
growing in people's gardens although
relatively unknown to the rest of the
world
the residents of Colombia know all too
well about the plant and its dangers
Colombian to make sure they never fall
asleep beneath a burro territory because
it's so toxic that even inhaling itself
for too long is enough to send an
individual into an agonizing trip for
days and even cause instant death there
are thousands of urban myths about the
burundanga drug and the horrific stories
that have become knows who've all
wittingly taken the drug one story
documented in a scientific paper tells
of a young man who amputated his own
tongue and penis after drinking just one
cup of tea made using for room Dunga the
drug basically suppresses your free will
and makes you susceptible to doing
absolutely anything you are told to it's
so effective in fact that it was used as
a truth serum by the CIA they got a
whole lot of truth
but they also got a load of stories
about purple elephants and other
complete rubbish because of its powerful
hallucinogenic properties in Colombia
the drug is never used for pleasure but
only for two purposes to rob or to kill
often by organized gangs it is common
for a gang member to blow the powder
into the face or wipe it across the nose
and mouth of an unsuspecting member of
the public within seconds the person is
under the drug powerful spell and
there's not a thing they can do to stop
it
once drug - the victim loses all self
will and will happily do whatever the
attacker asks even if it causes physical
or financial harm to themselves or
others the victim is then told to hand
over their wallet and even to drive to
their home and help the fief to empty
their own house of all the most
expensive possessions and hand them over
to the thieves which the drug forces
them to happily oblige to the worst part
about all of this is that the victim
isn't even aware that they're half so to
them it feels completely normal to want
to give away all that morning in
possessions and what makes this the
perfect criminal drug is that the victim
won't remember a single thing about the
incident not who gave it to them or what
the person made them do as one might
expect it's also used as a date-rape
drug however it's more commonly used by
prostitutes - robbing suspecting John's
and clubs pimps often supply their
prostitute of burundanga and the girls
and seduce susceptible looking men in
bars then when the men aren't looking
the women spike the victims drink with
the drug within a few minutes of the
victim ingesting the deadly liquor they
will either be dead because the dosage
was slightly too high which
unfortunately happens all too often in
Colombia or be completely at the mercy
of the prostitutes every command
it's then common for the women to drive
their victims all around town asking
them to withdraw all their monies from a
series of ATMs and hand it over which
they gladly oblige - because they have
lost their ability to
No and that's what truly makes this the
scariest drug in the world women have
also known to have been drugged with
burundanga and kidnapped then used as
prostitutes to earn money for the
kidnappers by keeping the women
continuously drugged for days they won't
put up any resistance and are in fact
extremely willing to do horrendous
things broomed anger or scopolamine as
it's known clinically is on the World
Health Organization's list of essential
medicines a list of the most important
medicines needed in a basic health
system as it's used in the medical field
in moderate doses to treat motion
sickness and suppress nausea it's
therefore crazy to think that in a
slightly higher dosage this substance
can be used for evil but then again what
more would you expect from Colombia the
drug capital of the Western world the
bottom line is where it could be weed
cocaine or scopolamine don't do drugs
it's just bloody stupid Owen don't go to
Colombia thanks for watching some photos
can tell rich detailed stories others
inspire a thousand questions the two and
a half thousand happy residents of my
akhi islands have nothing but good words
to say about their cozy little poke look
they are practically welcoming you with
open arms